open AI has a hundred and seventy five
billion parameter model you thought that
was large that's cute
check out google's 600 billion parameter
model 600 billion floating point numbers
doing things at the same time this has
absolutely become a body part measuring
competitions between companies Google be
like Oh GPT three two I spit on you I
spit on you and your little tiny hundred
fifty five billion okay let's stop
kidding this is a giant model that
Google has trained right here the paper
we're going to look at today is called
gee shard scaling giant models with
conditional computation and automatic
sharding by Dimitri lapekin at I love
Google and this paper basically tells
the story of how they built this 600
billion parameter model how actually
they attempted to build a model that had
a trillion parameters but just didn't
manage to quite train it and this is all
using this system called GE shard so I
haven't actually seen the code out 4G
shard yet but I'm going to maybe assume
that this is something that they're
gonna release at some point who knows or
maybe I just haven't seen it yet so this
is basically describing a system on how
to train these giant models so if you if
you have watched my video on GPT 3 which
of course was this a hundred and seventy
five billion parameter model of open AI
which already was record breaking you
this paper the paper was very much like
oh we built a model and look at what
things it can do so that was the open a
paper this paper here is like oh the
complete opposite
it basically says oh yeah we do language
model but but here is how we built the
model which is you know equally cool so
opening I basically just made everything
bigger and here they say to me
everything even bigger you need some
tricks and how to build models and
they've basically they've developed this
entire framework to build these giant
models and this paper mainly describes
that framework and the actual task here
which is machine translation is almost
sort of a side thing in the paper it's
it's oh it's just a task to showcase
what this system can do so this is very
much an engineering paper rather than
that much than a machine learning paper
and that's how you have to look at it
right here that being said the machine
learning results are of course quite
impressive if you look at this graph
here you have a quality gain it's a
difference in blur score and this is a
quality score for machine translation
over the previous state of the art so
over there baseline which as you can see
here you have 37-billion weights hundred
and fifty billion weights and 600
billion weights which they only train
they train for you know two thousand and
two thousand forty ATP use for just four
days that's they stress this is very
efficient because they just have to
train it for four days on two thousand
TP use absolutely crazy so let's have a
look at what this paper does if you
enjoy this if you enjoyed this at the
end consider you know sharing the video
out if you liked it and tell me what you
think about this stuff in the comments
alright so we'll go through the abstract
and then we'll go through highlighted
sections of the paper because the paper
is 23 pages long so I won't be able to
cover everything just kind of give you
the the high-level ideas and highlight a
few things actually let's not go into
the abstract let's go into yeah these
results first so as you can see they
managed to continue the trend the trend
in NLP has always been at least since
you know transformers were invented the
bigger the better like larger model
larger data more compute means better
performance and this is
sort of unbroken here as you can see if
you increase the number of parameters in
these models you do get a very very big
gain in these blow score though it sort
of seems to be kind of a logarithmic
scale in like you have to you have to
keep doubling and doubling and doubling
the the number of way it's sort of like
Moore's law in computation you can see
that at the same time the training wall
time is going down and the computational
cost the computational cost of these
models it doesn't scale quadratically
like you would expect it scales linearly
and that's the big difference here in
how these authors scale their model
rather than how the open AI authors
scaled their model so in a traditional
MA in M traditional transformer looks
like this so it has these blocks of
attention if you don't know what this is
I have a video called attention is all
you need
I explained how the attention blocks in
transformers work so this is nothing
different these are just transformers
standard transformers there is an
encoder and the decoder everything works
as you know so you oh you have these
blocks you have n blocks these are the
number of layers that you have and in
these blocks you always have an
attention layer and then a feed-forward
layer that acts on the tokens so without
repeating too much what an attention
mechanism does basically in you have
inputs tokens so this is a sequence it's
technically a set processing unit but we
use it for sequences of text so here you
have six tokens a sentence of maybe six
words and then you transform it with the
attention layer by having this attention
mechanism that routes information from
tokens to from positions to other
positions maybe like this route is here
route this year and then you have a
feed-forward network that is applied on
a per token basis so each of these
tokens now goes through this
feed-forward network and is
kind of transformed so the embedding of
that token is transformed by that feat
for network now every token does this
and it's always the same feed-forward
Network so this network here is the same
as this network now usually when we talk
about scaling transformers we talked
about this part right here we talked
about the attention mechanism and also
we talked about this part the number of
layers so you know we talked about
scaling the number of transformer layers
more layers more layers more layers and
if we want to scale the attention
mechanism what that basically means is
we have we increase the context size of
the text we can input so transformers
are very limited by the size of this
context right here that they can take
the like the original transformers
started with something like 512 tokens
that they were able to take because this
attention mechanism has quadratic
complexity this went up and the open a I
GPT 3 I believe had a context size of
2048 tokens which if it scales
quadratically that's quite an
achievement and also it stacked the
layers very very deep now in this paper
they scale the Transformers differently
they basically leave the context size
and I believe that their context size is
1,024 so significantly smaller than the
open era context size and they don't
scale the layers so their largest
transformer is 36 layers whereas I
believe GPT 3 was maybe correct me but I
think it was like 90 or a hundred layers
or something like this at least
significantly larger than this instead
what they scale is this part right here
the feed-forward layers now that might
seem counterintuitive but they basically
they basically say what if we didn't
only have one feed-forward Network right
here but we had many right we don't
always have the same we have many many
feed-forward networks different ones
that can do different things so that's
what they call experts
each one of these feet
or layers is an expert and then you have
yet another routing mechanism kind of
like in attention you have a routing
mechanism that decides which tokens go
where okay so this token here this token
here this token here and the sort of the
implication being that different tokens
different parts of the input
you wanna transform require a different
kind of transformations here and these
different experts can sort of specialize
in how they transform the inputs now
their task here is going to be machine
translation as a multitask setup so what
you'll have is you'll have all kinds of
languages like French and German what's
that's de and maybe expect a lot of
languages I don't know any other
languages and you want to translate all
of them to English and you want to do it
using the same model right so these
experts here they might specialize in
you know the individual languages like
maybe you will have to handle a pronoun
differently if it comes from German than
if it comes from French you want to do
it with the same model at the same time
that means you maybe want to have the
one expert specialize in German pronouns
and one expert specialize in French
pronounce also you can think of the
experts as maybe one specializes in
question words it doesn't matter which
language they're from and the other one
specializes in some sort of other kind
of linguistic feature in any case this
number of experts here is if you want to
scale that up then that becomes the
bottleneck of the transformer they go up
to 2000 2048 experts in parallel so that
doesn't fit into a single accelerator
anymore and that's why the entire system
has to be sharded and that's what they
call GE chart so G shard the main
application here is going to be how how
can we build this giant model in on many
many distributed computers
where the attention mechanism isn't the
problem the attention mechanism we just
distribute like we do data parallelism
the attention it lives on all of the
accelerators it synchronizes and so on
but the experts here there is only so
this expert lives on machine a this
expert lives on machine B this expert
lives on machine C and then we do a hard
routing so we don't do a soft routing
like an attention we do a hard routing
where one token goes to one or at
maximum to experts so this is sent to
these machines and then after the
machines you kind of gather all the
results back right here so G shard is
the system that enables this charting of
these experts and the everything in
between everything that is necessary but
it can also be applied to shard any
computation and that's why it's so cool
so here you see what what they do they
always they take these transformers and
they always consider a block of two
transformer layers so this is a block of
two transformer layers you can see there
is twice the attention and there's twice
this feed-forward so in one point this
feed-forward is just a regular
everything all the tokens go through the
same network so that's like a classic
transformer but here you have a lot of
these different experts and the tokens
are routed to these experts it's
important that the tokens are hard
routed right if the tokens were soft
routed you don't you don't gain anything
because every token has to go through
every expert but here the tokens are
hard routed to the expert which means
that you can if you if I have an input
size of 1,024 tokens maybe only 10 go to
this one and maybe only 10 of that lows
go to this one now you also have a batch
size of course I haven't actually looked
at what the batch size here is but you
usually have quite a large batch size in
these things like maybe a batch size of
a thousand as well so ultimately what
you'll end up is you know a thousand
times ten
tokens going to the first expert and so
on but still you can significantly
paralyze this computation okay so this
this if you use G chart this is going to
result in the following
in the thing on the right where you have
two machines this is machine one and
this is machine two you can see that the
machines will what happened here ah
someone made the PowerPoint mistake so
you can see that the the attention
everything is shared between the
machines so this here and this here
these are synchronized the waits are
synchronized right you simply do a a
data sharing but here you can see that
you have model parallelism multiple
parallel mixture of experts we're on the
first machine you have the first expert
and then you have II II devices and on
the last one you have the last expert
and then it's all routed out and routed
in again and then you can continue your
transformer and this is layer after
layer so what's the problem here the
problem is that an operation like this
is going to come to incur significant
sort of overhead in terms of
communication and so on if you were to
do it naively and it's going to be a
real pain to program this and that's why
gee shard is made to do all of this
automatically and you don't you you
don't incur much of a cost because you
distribute so what's the difference -
the old scaling why don't they just make
Transformers larger in number of layers
and that's because this this is I guess
what open he ran into as well if you
make transformers simply larger in
number of layers sorry if you make it a
Transformers larger in the attention
mechanism it just won't fit into memory
at some point and deal you'll have to
sharp that somehow and you can do this
with gee shard if you scale it in a
number of layers that incurs significant
costs where you have to wait because you
have to forward propagate
it and then you have to backward
propagate in your training sequence and
if you have just too many layers then a
lot of the a lot of the frameworks get
at their limit where at some point they
say well I still have to wait for the
signal to come back in order to continue
and they explore this in this benchmark
right here you can see they say the
largest model the 600 billion parameter
model that achieved the best translation
quality was trained with 2000 TPU V 3
cores for three days a total cost of 22
TPU couriers in contrast training all
100 bilingual baseline models would have
required 29 couriers so the model here
is faster than if you train them
individually but if you want to train a
single transformer that is just very
deep and achieves a reasonable
performance you have to invest a lot
more our best quality dense single
transformer model 2.3 billion parameters
so it's also significantly smaller
achieving this was trained with G pipe
which is a previous framework so G pipe
is kind of a task runner that also
distributes computation was trained with
G pipe on 2048 TPU cores for six weeks
or a total of 235 TPU core years by the
way for if you if you have $1 per TPU
hour that'll only cause a lonely I guess
set you back about two million or so
easy-peasy
or even two hundred thousand just you
know a tiny tiny bit of money but you
can see that this transformer model that
is dense which means that is a classic
transformer where you stack the
transformer layers you stack them you
stack them you stack them it in fact it
has 96 layers there Bay
96 layer transformer model that's sort
of what opening I did they just kept
stacking the transformer layers you get
a model that has less parameters and
trains for much longer and it's
performance is only about this good
whereas here if you scale not into depth
but into width of these experts and it's
not dense but it's Charlotte which means
it calculates this in a in a kind of
sparsa fide way because it has this hard
routing you can scale up to a lot more
parameters so 600 billion parameters
over 200 times more parameters than the
deep model and you can get a much better
performance okay so this is what is
different here it scales into these
experts rather than scaling into depth
or or size of the attention mechanism
itself all right think the question I
guess that you come up with if you're a
machine learner is how do you back
propagate if you route if here you route
to these different experts and you do a
hard routing like here how do you back
propagate the signal because it seems
like you need a soft routing but this
has been handled in fact these mixture
of experts has been introduced
previously in a paper I think called
outrageously large language models or
something like this sent and so they've
introduced that you know it it still
works so back prop still works through
so basically you have a back prop path
through here and because you put a
little bit of noise in this routing
every path gets explored a few times and
therefore you have enough back prop
signal to make it work it can it could
technically fail but they do observe
generally that it does work if you do
this kind of hard routing with a bit of
noise all right so where do we go from
here as I said this is an engineering
paper and it's a long engineering paper
so they they set up their they set up a
lot of a lot of the details of
engineering directly in the paper which
we're not used to in the machine learn
world they really detail how they shard
things and so on which is pretty cool
but um I invite you to look at the paper
yourself if you really want to know
what's going on right here suffice to
say they as you can see right here what
they do is this is the input right here
and then they have this weight matrix
which is a dis routing this is learned
routing weights okay so you have
trainable weights that decide how to
route the input and that's dependent on
the input so you have a bunch of inputs
that comes from the lower layer and this
matrix right here determines where to
route them basically says okay the input
is a vector like this I know that must
probably go to the expert number three
okay and you have a softmax across that
so it's a really it's an assignment -
it's a soft assignment to the experts so
once you've done the soft assignment to
the expert you do a hard assignment by
collecting the top two for each token
you could say you collect the top two
experts and you only send it to the top
two experts and you ignore all else
which is not a lot right there at times
there are 2,000 experts in the system
and yeah you distribute and you have
some noise so with a random probability
you actually don't even send it to the
second expert you just leave it at the
first one and with some noise you send
it also to the second one and I think
that that noise is part of what if what
makes the system work of it and then you
also have this auxiliary loss right here
that you add on top which just makes
sure that you distribute evenly so this
encourages the system to distribute the
tokens evenly because sorry what it
penalizes
is a this here is the mean assignment to
each expert so it penalizes whenever the
mean assignment is out of out of line
basically so eight a distribution
assignment to the expert where one
expert gets a lot of tokens because I
don't know it happens to be really good
at something so all the tokens are
routed to it and the other expert don't
get a lot that's penalized so you
encourage the system to distribute
tokens evenly between those experts and
then there are also like upper limits
where you drop tokens and so on they
really build a system that is out for
performance rather than machine learning
correctness
so they demonstrate how to do this in in
sort of code with their system and the
cool thing about their system is that
you don't have to do much what you'll
have to do is just specify which tensors
are Charlotte at along which dimensions
and the system does the rest so this is
pretty cool so this here is this mixture
of experts mixture of experts as you
would write it in code and they make use
a lot of this in some of this Einstein
some notation if you don't know what the
Einstein some notation is it's a general
notation to describe matrix or tensor
multiplications so a for example if you
were to multiply two matrices you could
have a string there you describe it as a
string and it comes from how how
Einstein wrote up the kind of tensor
contractions in his work so if you
wanted multiply two matrices you can you
could put the string a b b c goes to a c
so this and then you put two matrices
right here this would tell it okay i
have a one matrix I'm going to call the
axis a and B I have another matrix or
tensor where I'm going to call the axis
B and C now I have the result
ten sir and I want the first access to
be a and the a is this one and I want
the last access to be C and the C is
this one and B is nowhere B is not in
the output which means it should
contract over B so it should sum along B
sir it should multiply along B and then
add so it should contract over B so this
here it describes a regular matrix
matrix multiplication now if I I could
do something else I could do something
like a just a element-wise product an
element-wise product would be something
like this a B comma a B goes to a B
which means here I have a in the first
input and here I have a again and I'm so
you already see that you can even though
these are different tensors you can call
the axis the same which means that
they're going to somehow be multiplied
together now if you leave it away here
it means that it's going to be
contracted and therefore the axis no
longer exists but here we don't leave it
away which simply means that these axes
are going to be multiplied together and
the same for B right here so this
describes an element-wise
this describes an element-wise product
you can go really funky with this so
this this here would be a a row wise dot
product where a is mod it for all the
A's its element wise but then over B its
contracted so you know you can go you
can go wild with the Einstein some
notation you can describe a lot of
things with it so here is this algorithm
to distribute the computation among
these different experts so you have the
inputs and the weight matrix for the
they call this the gates function that's
the routing function to these experts so
what do we do we first of all we have
these tensors
this they have this grouping this
grouping dimension right here so they
come along with to along groups which in
our case we could maybe say these are
batches or the batch dimension so they
come across groups and there is the
sequence length and there is this M
right here that's going to be the
feature dimension the M and you can see
the M is contracted so the M is no
longer here so the gating function is
going to route each input token right
here to one of the experts for each
thing in the group so you can see you
can express this with an Einstein some
notation then you have a top to gating
which selects the top two from each of
the last from from each of the entries
and that gives you this dispatch mask
and the sorry and the weights that you
have to use at the end to combine you
can use the dispatch mask in order to
distribute the inputs so you have
reshaped inputs and so on so I'm not
going to go through all of this right
here but you can express all of this in
terms of the Einstein some notation and
you can express pretty much any sort of
computation that is along the line you
can express the attention mechanism and
so on you can express the feed-forward
layers in terms of these Einstein some
notations and the underlying the
underlined dimensions here are the
dimensions where we want to shard the
computation so here because we have this
G underlined that means that we are
interested in sharding the computation
along this axis so this I said this is
the batch dimension this is your classic
data parallelism which means that the
first machine gets the first couple of
data points the second machine gets the
second couple of data points and so on
and you can see in the weight matrix
there is no sharding which means that
the weight matrix lives on every machine
as a copy of one another this is
different from from here where you can
see that what we're now going to do is
here it's still shorted according to the
batch but we now are going to short this
according to the different experts so
we're going to route whatever the inputs
are in to these experts and then we're
going to execute the computations on the
expert so this is now sharded according
to the experts and at the end right here
you can see this is still shorted
according to the experts we're going to
put it back together and now it's
charted according to the groups again
that's what we said we have the input
right here the inputs and the inputs are
maybe distributed according to the
according to machines read we have these
go through the first machine these the
second these the third and so on this is
your classic data parallelism but then
we have all of these experts and now all
of a sudden we're going to route these
things to the individual experts and
we're going to execute the computation
in parallel on the experts and then
after that we're going to put back
together from wherever we got them now
after so this goes here again and so
this is just the reverse of what we did
before it lit up right like that so you
get all of the outputs again I hope you
kind of can imagine how this happens so
the first difference is is that's
charted according to a different
dimension and the second difference is
is that when we shard in data
parallelism we execute the same
computation on all the machines which
means that we have the same weight
matrix if we do a
times W in a feed-forward layer and we
shard this thing here in data
parallelism what we do is we send the X
to different machines we split the X we
send it to different machines this is X
1 X 2 X 3 X 4 but we always multiply it
with the same weight matrix that weight
matrix lives on all of the machines and
is regularly synchronized it's kept
synchronous in some way whereas if we
shard X to the experts
then the experts have individual
functions so the expert 1 is different
from the expert 2 is different from the
expert 3 and so on which means that
before it wasn't important where X was
routed because we would execute the same
computation so we can just you know
shard it according to you know the first
10 go there the legs 10 go there but
here it's now crucially important where
they are route a 2/2 which expert and
that's why we learn the function that is
going to route them so this is learned
this is this first line here these are
the weights that we learn to route then
we're out right here and we calculate
your your we calculate the feed-forward
layers on the expert you see that this
wi and wo they are the weight matrices
of the feed-forward layer the
feed-forward layers are you have your
input you x wi you have a ray lu ray lu
and then you multiply it by wo so it's
kind of a two layer feed-forward network
so this two layer feed-forward network
as you can see this is charted according
to the experts and then and the in the
important part is of course that here
the weight is also Charlotte according
to the experts and that's what makes
each expert different and then it's
combined again down here so I hope you
kind of get the idea of what this
algorithm does and the fact that we
chart according to these experts is in
fact
different than your regular sharding
where you showed the data like the batch
the batches but keep the model in
parallel keep the model synchronized
with their system right now this is how
easy this is
so before we simply stated our algorithm
in Einstein some notations there is no
way to underline code and that magically
happens something that was simply for us
to visualize now we want to apply their
system in order to make this actually
Charlotte and with the G short system
and as I said I don't know if the code
is out or it will be out but with the G
short system this is basically all that
you have to do so you have these
functions they're called split and
replicate what replicate does is it
takes that weight tensor and it
replicates it on all the machines and
that keeps it synchronized right this is
a computation where we simply want to
short out the different to the different
machines but keep it synchronized and
you can see if you do this this is the
operation then the system knows ah this
this here is replicated across the
machines so that means I'm going to
distribute the data points according to
this G damage according to the batch
dimension and multiply it with this
matrix according to this Einstein some
notation string on all of the machines
and I'm going to keep this tensor in
sync
okay so the system knows as opposed to
that you have you have the split tensor
right here so the split what it does is
it splits a computation here the
dispatch expert inputs it splits it
according to a access index on to D
different machines or in to D different
parts so you see here you calculate the
how you should do the
and the resulting tensors first
dimension is this e dimension and then
you say that should be split you know
according to this first dimension on to
D different places and these D different
places are now separate they don't have
the they don't have to be kept and think
everyone has their own weights and now
when you do this you know according to
this new dimension you can see because
we know Einstein some notation now you
can see this e appears here here and
here so this operation is going to be
applied element wise that means
independent of each other
in the direction of this dimension the
system understands that since this
tensor is charted according to that
dimension I have to execute this on each
of these entries in separate with on
each expert having their own weight
matrix right here I hope this is a bit
clear that their system makes it super
easy you can basically do two things you
can say this thing here is my classic
parallelism where I want to keep it in
sync and this thing here is where I want
to split up and do different computation
on the different parts and then they
have a also a general function that is
more powerful
yeah they and they you can auto
partition and whatnot so they have a a
come they have this we implemented the
petitioner in the excel a compiler which
means that anything that can translate
to excel a is a target for this system
and that's you know tensorflow and pi
torch can do this so technically this
can come to any of those systems but of
course who has their 2000 TP use lying
around to make use of this but no I'm
kidding I mean this I they here use it
for transformers but I am very excited
to to see what people can
up with for the system I believe a
system like this where it's super easy
to to shard and they have some you know
they talk about okay we do these single
machine compiler so the compiler is also
fast and so on I don't even want to go
into this but this is very well
engineered it seems and they they they
basically implement this for all of the
operators so I'm very excited to see
what people can come up with outside of
the traditional applications I think
there can be new types of models
developed simply because we have a
system like this that makes it easier so
yeah I'm excited so here they show a bit
how this works on the example of this
Einstein
some notation so here we want to do this
thing here which if you remember this is
the operation where we want to route the
input to these experts so we want to
start with something that is chartered
according to the batch dimension that
means that we you know we have different
different parts of the batch on
different machines and we want to route
this and finally end up with something
that is Charlotte on the different
experts so this is what the system does
is first you have these here are the
different shards right you want to
multiply this as you can see this and
this right here means that these this
routing table is also Charlotte
according to the same machines so you
have the zero is all in the same machine
the one is all on the same machine and
so on so what you want to do is you want
to contract you is there you want to
contract according to this s dimension
right which we have we have omitted
right here
and if you multiply that uh sorry okay
we omit the s so this is not much of a
this is not much of a a very graphic
right here but then they have this
rashard operation where they do and you
don't have to worry about this so from
here to here there is this rashard
operation that just shards it according
to the according to E yeah I find this
to be a bit more a bit more insightful
so if you have something like this
this which is a regular matrix
multiplication right and you want to
contract along B this is exactly the
example we had before so here is a
situation where our tensor is charted
according to the B dimension and this
tensor is also shorted according to the
B dimension and you want to do a matrix
multiplication of the whole tensor so
what can you do you're supposed to
multiply these two matrices but they are
shorted on different machines now if you
consider what you actually have to do is
you have to multiply each row here with
each column here and that in an
element-wise fashion so that distributes
according to you have to multiply this
by this Plus this by this Plus this by
this plus the red by the red so you can
simply multiply the zero tensors
together the one tensors together the
two tensors together and the three
tensors together each one will give you
a full matrix and then you can simply
add all of them in order to get your
full results this is illustrated down
here so what Machine one does it simply
multiplies its shard by its own shard of
the second matrix which will give it
this thing here and by the nature of how
matrix multiplication is constructed you
can simply do an all
which means you reduce you sum across
all of the machines and that will give
you the full result so this is a this is
a an example of how this works this is
you know pretty simple and I believe you
may have seen something like this
already when you were looking at just
parallelizing matrix multiplication and
so on so this system handles this
transparently right if you're shorted
like this this is what the system will
do however if you are shorted
differently
the system will act differently so here
is a system you want to do the same
matrix multiplication but the first
tensor happens to be shorted according
to the AAA dimension the second tensor
happens to be shorted according to the C
dimension and you want to end up with
something that's shorted to the C
dimension now we have an additional
constraint here that here you can see we
kind of assumed that this full thing
here fits into memory mainly because we
want to obtain the full result you see
here a and C should not be shorted so we
assume that we can keep that in memory
but here we want the final result to be
shorted according to see which appllo
imposes the additional constraint that
it might be that the full matrix never
fits into memory so how are we going to
calculate all of that we can't do the
same trick anymore now this g short
system apparently realizes itself when
something is out of memory and it can do
a smart a smart move around being out of
memory using a loop which basically
means that it will compute entry by
entry or block by block so these are the
matrices we have to multiply and you can
see that if I want to do multiply this
by this that's fine I can do this on one
machine but and that will give me the
block up here but if I want the block up
here I have to multiply this by this
which is across two different machines
so what this system does is it's going
into a while loop because it realizes
there's not enough memory
and it kind of sends around these
different slices to the different parts
each time computing a little piece so
here first we do this by this this is
fine but then we grab ourselves from the
we we grab ourselves this one here
calculate the next little piece up here
and then we grab ourselves the number to
calculate the piece here and then so
this is from zero this is from two the
one we already had and then we grab
ourselves piece three and multiply that
until here until we have this final
slice that we want okay so this goes in
a while loop in multiple rounds the
system gets knows itself when it has to
do this and when it can calculate the
full thing at once because it fits into
in memory it's even smarter than that in
that it can do these halo exchanges so
if you have to do something like this a
convolution now in a convolution what
you'll do if you think of a think of an
image and you want to do a convolution
on it but the image happens to be
sharded let's say the image is so large
it's sharded across nine different
machines like this now if you want to do
a convolution that's pretty cool you
know here here here but here all of a
sudden your convolution is across two
different machines so this system G
shard will adapt automatically and do
these hallo exchanges where it kind of
sends around from this machine it'll
send something to this machine such that
it can do the convolution in that step
and vice versa and then this can be a
padded accordingly as you can see this I
I think this is this is this was like
super ugly to implement if you just
imagine that for each of these
operations you have to think about okay
how can i express this with these MPI
primitives like dynamic slice and
collective permute and so on
it's just an absolute nightmare
and I'm very happy that other people
have done this and I probably just get
to use it so there is a lot more to this
system than I've just explained I just
try to give you a flavor of what
building a system like this means and
how easy it is to use it like this in
order to implement all of this mixture
of experts things you simply go from
this which is a one a single machine
implementation how you would write it to
this which is now the same it's almost
the same code but this now you can run
on however many machines and if you
compile it with the system it will do
what you expect it to do in this sharded
way completely crazy ok so they apply
this to massively multilingual massive
machine translation so two things it's
massively multilingual and it's massive
machine which means I guess a lot of
machines and the the reason here is is
twofold so what they say is we have
massively multilingual translation why
don't they just look at you know single
machine translation and it has a very
specific reason namely if you have
massively multilingual translation which
means that you have a lot of like
different languages and you all have to
translate them ideally to all the other
languages or you know every language
pair but in this case they only look at
all the languages to English I don't
exactly know why but I guess there must
be some kind of reason if you do this
then you can make use of two of a where
there are languages that you just don't
have much data on like I I don't I don't
I don't know Basque or something like
this there's just not that many people
speaking Basque
or Swiss German there isn't there's not
even a written form a standard written
form of Swiss German so you just don't
have to as many resources and for other
languages you have giant amounts of
resources and what you can make use of
is this phenomenon called positive
language transfer where it happens that
for example Swiss German is very close
to German now they can't understand us
which is a giant advantage for us but
still it shares a lot of similarities
with German so if you learn a lot about
German you can sort of transfer a learn
to Swiss German pretty easily so you if
you have a system that does German and
Swiss German at the same time you can
perform better on both languages because
the the swiss german part of your model
into the motor part of your model that
the swiss german profits from the german
inputs as well
now don't understand me wrong there is
not an individual part of your model
that for each language it's all done at
the same time but still you can imagine
that you know some of these things will
specialize in some of the languages but
the hope is that if you have German and
Swiss German in the same training set
that if the model realizes what a
question construct is in German it will
be able to apply that also to Swiss
German with some minor modification so
there is a benefit of having these many
languages especially for the low
resource languages okay so as the number
of languages sorry as the number of
language pairs to be modeled within a
single translation model increases
positive language transfer starts to
deliver large gains for low resource
languages given the number of languages
considered which I believe is a hundred
here m4 has a clear advantage on
improving the low resource task on the
contrary for high resource languages the
increased number of tasks limit per task
capacity within the model resulting in
lower translation quality
compared to a models to moe to a models
trained on a single language pair this
capacity bottleneck for high resource
languages can be relaxed by increasing
the model size to massive scale in order
to satisfy the need for additional
capacity some basically are saying we
can if we train all these languages
together that will help a lot for these
low resource languages but it might hurt
the high resource languages because now
we would have enough data technically to
train and French to English model on in
you know this giant model we could train
that and now that we have all these
other languages in there it just hurts
us because we don't have enough
parameters and we can solve this of
course by simply adding more parameters
so that's the solution add more
parameters and you you increase the
capacity of the model and you still get
the benefits of the positive language
transfer so their investigations is
going to be into how much can we scale
this and is there like a sweet spot
where because if you if you increase the
parameters too much you counteract this
positive language transfer again so
since you know since Swiss German and
German can sort of benefit from each
other however if we have too many
parameters so and then we end up having
all of these experts right here and the
tokens are always routed to these
experts and it always happens that all
the Swiss German tokens are always
routed to this experts and all the
German tokens are always routed to that
expert there will be no sharing of of
weights there will be this positive
language transfer will not happen
because we have too much capacity so the
goal is to find a sweet spot between
positive language transfer and this
capacity bottleneck they do use an
in-house data set which we don't have
access to but they say the training
corpus mined from the web contains
parallel documents for 100 languages to
and from English adding up to a total of
25 billion training examples however
they only use
from 100 languages to English this
result in approximately 13 billion
training examples to be used for model
training so that's a lot it's a lot of
data especially for translations it's
kind of noisy translation because it's
mine from the web but still it's a lot
of data they have a base lines so the
base lines are first of all in order to
form our base lines we trained separate
bilingual neural machine translation
models for each language pair so that
means a single model for each language
to English tune depending on the
available training data per language
and then they also have a they also have
a base line where they try opening a
style to build as deep as single
transformer as possible and by that they
mean we also include a variant of a
dense 96 layer transformer
encoder/decoder Network train with G
pipe pipeline parallelism on the same
data set as another baseline so the
difference again here is that this 96
layer is a dense transformer which means
that all of the tokens go through the
same computation and we don't charge the
computation out to these experts right
we do shard according to the batch but
all of them go through the same
parameters and that means we can we can
only scale up the number of layers and
that severely limits the that severely
limits the computational efficiency even
if we have you know your pipeline
parallelism and so on that hurts
they say training to convergence took
over six weeks on two thousand TPU
course that's crazy but I guess yeah you
know I was saying earlier that that I
always thought we were happy
I always thought we were happy and
machine learning because kind of the the
hip science fields being biology like
genetic
and machine learning was thought like Oh
but these biology people they always
need like million-dollar grants from
government to run their experiments and
we can just sit down with a laptop oh
this time is over if you start a PhD now
start applying for money to get TP use
yeah okay in any case here you can see
what this does so they compare a bunch
of models right here so this T this is
this big dense transformer that's going
to be one of our base lines and the
other base line here is going to be the
zero axis the zero axis means this is
the signal model for that language pair
so only so for each language they
trained one model only on data from that
language and that's going to be the
worst thing here because this this
multi-language translation in one model
will generally help you if you have
enough parameters you can see all the
models here have enough parameters such
that the difference here that this is
difference in blue is positive including
this baseline model right here so the
baseline model as you can see has 2.3
billion parameters even though it takes
that much longer to Train and that's as
we said a function of the fact that it's
dense and deep that hurts in training
efficiency and then you have this
mixture of expert models they always
consider two things they consider
different numbers of experts you can see
goes from 128 to 2048 experts and they
consider a number different number of
layers from 12 layers to 36 layers
36 layers still being way smaller than
the 96 layer transformer here and that's
the reason why it trains faster so it it
doesn't train faster so the reason it
trains faster is because it has less
layers and then the reason it has more
parameters is because it has a lot of
these experts and the
art here is to constrain how much these
more experts hurt you so you know you
could run into the same problem where if
you scale up the experts in fact you do
it doesn't fit into memory anymore and
it's going to hurt you a lot in training
efficiency kind of like if you increase
the number of layers but the G short
system prevents that it lets you up the
number of experts without incurring the
cost that being said it does not let you
up the number of layers you're going to
incur the same cost if you up the number
of layers as you have with the dense
transformers so does this help it helps
a lot as you can see right here there's
a general trend upwards and what's the x
axis the x axis is low resource
languages so you can see that as we as
we go to lower and lower resource
languages this multitasks training this
multilingual translation improves
significantly over the baseline where we
only trained a system for that language
specifically and these 10k examples it's
a it's a it's quite a bit but it's not
that much especially since it's noisy
data so this is specifically good for
low resource languages but you can see
also the high resource languages here
benefit from the multilingual
translation and that's a function of the
fact that we have you know large enough
models in fact you can see the larger
the models the more the difference in
blow is and there's not really an end in
sight and they also see it say that they
haven't seen convergence in training so
you can technically train this you know
forever yeah you can also see that the
the lowest mixture of experts right here
is almost on par with their big dense
transformer that took so much longer to
train right so this lowest model right
here I believe it took I don't want to
go back but it took it took hours or so
or a few hours to train whereas this 96
layer dense transformer took
there is six weeks to Train though has
to be said the number of TP use is not
to be neglected but if your Google you
know you just have them laying around
what's also interesting here and you can
start seeing this two things first of
all you can see that the difference
between here in between the dense
transformer and this baseline model is
very low for high resource languages but
gets larger for low resource languages
this is an indication that the dense
transformer it does more to share
parameters between the languages because
it shares parameters between all the
things because all the tokens go through
the same computation so it is going to
be a bit better in low resource
languages but still the general trend
upwards holds even for the mixture of
experts the second thing is that you see
there is a crossover here in these in
these big in these biggest models and
what are the big models one the blue one
is the one with 2048 experts and the
green one is the one with 500 experts
they're both as deep models but all of a
sudden over here for the high resource
languages it's still true that if you up
the number of parameters you get a
benefit so up the number of experts as
well you get a benefit but over here for
the low resource languages it's it you
see it actually hurts you to up the
number of experts and that's the
phenomenon exactly we talked about
before if you have too many of these
experts and you do a hard routing that
means all the tokens go a different way
and that means you don't get any sharing
benefit from the multilingual
translation and they investigate a lot
and they basically claim that there is
sweet spot of expert in their particular
task appears to be somewhere in between
these two thousand and this 500 expert
number
where you can see it doesn't always help
you to scale up the model though I have
to say maybe the Transformers maybe they
need a ResNet moment so I believe in
computer vision it was sort of the same
problem that we try to build deeper
models and why like okay this this is
more width but yeah I think there might
be some breakthrough on the horizon
where someone just figures out how to
train these giant models even more giant
transformer models with deeper layers
and then there's a new new era of
transformers however this is not that
effect I'm sorry I said this at the
wrong place this is not that effect this
is to show that in this case we do
benefit for the high resource languages
because we increase capacity but for the
low resource languages we suffer if we
up the number of experts too much
because they don't share any parameters
anymore between the languages or between
the different parts like it's not a
necessity that the different languages
are going to be routed to different
experts but it's probably going to
happen right there's no hard coded thing
that says if it's this language it needs
to go there it just probably is going to
happen this way because the different
languages are going to be needed to be
treated differently and therefore the
system learns to route first and
foremost those two different experts
here you can see the model sizes
including this 60 layer models model
with 2000 experts that they didn't
manage to train they said they had
numerical instability but that had one
trillion parameters and I'm pretty sure
they're they're cool they must be quite
mad about this right like you have yes
the trillion parameters even though it's
not that much bigger than the 600
billion that that's really it would be
cool to write a paper like a trillion
parameter model but for now they are at
the 600 billion mark and they simply
want to tell you that they have actually
compiled a model that's that
big just didn't manage to train it and
yeah that's here here is where I wanted
to say that maybe we're waiting for the
resonate moment where all of a sudden
someone figures something out that makes
the training of basically infinitely
deep transformers possible like we make
the training for almost infinitely deep
with CNN's possible with ResNet ok so
they conclude this and so they that's
the the investigation of what the number
of experts and so on gives you and here
is a bit of a different investigation
where they more care about training
efficiency so they ask themselves how
many billion tokens of input do we need
to reach a Steven cross-entropy
so here the more tokens you need the
lower your efficiency is right you can
see that the general trend is the
following if if you up the number of
layers you get more efficient you can
see and just look at this column for now
this point seven column you can see it
already pretty clearly so here you go
from 12 layers to 36 you gain efficiency
here you gain here you gain pretty
predictable if you up the number of
layers you need to see fewer tokens to
get to the same cross-entropy and in
fact you can get to a lower cross
entropy all together at the end we've
known this for language models already
the other effect is of course what
happens if we go not deeper but wider if
we increase these number of experts if
we increase this sparse computation so
here you can see let's just look at the
12 layers for now let's look at all the
rows where there's 12 layers so here you
get a significant advantage by upping
the number of experts from 100 to 500
but then you hurt upping the number of
experts
mm right so that's that's sort of your
herding efficiency by upping the number
of experts too much and the same if we
look at the 36 layer so you gain massive
efficiency by upping the number of
experts but you lose that fish part of
that efficiency again by increasing it
even more now we saw that the this model
is still the best model but it's not as
efficient as that model and that gives
you another indication that there is
sort of a sweet spot between these two
things between the positive transfer and
the bottleneck capacity that appears to
be somewhere in between right here so
that's pretty interesting because we
know about depth that you can basically
up and up and up and get more efficient
but with not that much yeah the largest
model can be trained in under four days
to achieving the best quality yes yes
yes but this is just uh yeah
so here oh you can see the the batch
size in in tokens is quite quite a bit
so yeah if you have a thousand if you
have a context window of a thousand that
means the batch size here was about four
thousand so as as expected yeah this is
just easy-peasy 22 TPU couriers I've
seen someone on Twitter saying this this
is the new measure for some case no it's
no longer like flops
it's a TPU core you just mad mad and
yeah so 42 days to train this thing
right here crazy crazy crazy all right
they also have a number of
investigations in other parts of
efficiency like per device memory
consumption you can see
here that as you up the as you up the
number of experts you can see here here
here your weights don't go up because as
you up the number of experts you can
just up the number of machines and the
per machine weight usage will be the
same right because the experts are
independent of each other each one has
their own weight matrix so you can just
add machines and you keep your weight
requirements the same however if you go
deeper then your weights increase
because you're now deeper you have more
layers you have your so also your
transformer weights will be higher and
so on so you go deeper right here you
see 3660 layers your memory consumption
increases for the weight and also this
is the other big part in transformers
right the activations that you have to
save because as we said if you have a
transformer and I have layer layer layer
layer I basically have to keep around
each of these signals in order to do
back propagation and that's why also the
activation here increases as I go deeper
now you can see percentual II it
decreases again here so what's happening
technically you don't have to keep these
things around you can also once the
signal comes back you can recompute them
from the beginning or from an
intermediate point now this increases
computation but saves the need to store
the activations and apparently gee shard
yet another thing it does is it will
recompute as necessary the activations
if it realizes that you don't have
enough memory to store them so all of
this is pretty crazy honestly and they
come they look at where the where the
different computations go and I don't
want to go into this and they have these
my
kro benchmarks where they really show
that the the increase in complexity is
really according to square root of n
because that's how long it takes to
distribute to distribute along these
actors sorry along these experts there's
a lot to this paper and there's no time
to go through all of it I think this
video is already way too long I hope I
have given you an impression of what's
possible with this system and as I said
I'm excited what people can come up with
just to say that in the appendix here
they detail that they have done this for
all the operations in Excel a so for
example convolution this is so ugly how
you have to implement the convolution
because if the padding must be correct
across these expert across T the sharded
machine so there are no experts anymore
this is just G short the padding has to
be correct this strides have to be
correct and data needs to be exchanged
according to the machines the window
size needs to be correct
bla bla bla it's thank you for doing
this and not having to do it myself yeah
I'm excited as soon as the codes out
I'll if I get a hold of it I'll you know
link it or you'll find it once it's out
if it's already out I'm just too dumb to
see it I enjoyed reading this it's
different than a machine learning paper
it kind of shows you what goes into
engineering a system like this and how
easy it can be if it's engineered well
to then apply it I think this is going
to be extremely helpful to the community
and with that said 23 pages later see
you next time bye bye